it's time for the launch in chrono scope
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
watch company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene chrome scope from the CBS
television news staff larry lesser and
lewis banks associate editor of Time
magazine our distinguished guest for
this evening is the honorable Chet
Hollifield representative from
California tomorrow weather permitting
the third and greatest of the hydrogen
bomb test conducted by the United States
will take place in the Far Pacific and
tonight we're fortunate enough to have
as our guest a member of the Joint
Congressional Atomic Energy Committee
flew as present and privileged to see
one of those hydrogen bomb blasts that
shook the world representative
Hollifield may I ask you in a word were
you frightened when I saw the effect of
the March first blast and the effect of
the blast in 19 and 52 I was filled with
Wonder and all that man could create a
force that would be so powerful as to
create that tremendous hole in the ocean
coral bed we're an island was before the
representative hollifield has been a lot
of criticism all the United States among
our lives overseas about these hydrogen
bomb tests and some of this criticism
has been in the field that scientists
are delving into the unknown they don't
know what's going to happen now do you
share these fears well scientists always
delve into the unknown I do not share
those fears and I believe that the
highly vocal minority of foreign people
who have been against this have been
against it to either because of
propaganda which has been fed to them by
subversive forces in their country are
because of a lack of understanding of
the reason that it is necessary for us
to have these tests representative
Hollifield the bomb has gotten into the
news likely in kind of another way I
think Senator McCarthy is charged and
other people have echoed the fact that
there was an unreasonable delay in our
decision to go ahead with the h-bomb
project after we knew the Russians
exploded in a bomb and that this perhaps
was attributable to communist influence
now you were on the inside of a
committee all during that time what is
your comment on that my comment on that
is that I believe that Senator McCarthy
was badly misinformed the 18 members of
the Joint Committee on atomic energy
have issued a statement clarifying this
matter in September of 1949 the first
Russian a bomb was exploded four months
later after consideration by the Joint
Committee on atomic energy the Atomic
Energy Commission the Joint Chiefs of
Staff the general Advisory Committee in
the president's office again I repeat
four months later President Truman
ordered the go-ahead on the hydrogen
bomb project in January in January of
1954 months later what happened during
those four months sir during that four
months there was a great deal of
briefing going on in these different
government agencies a great deal of
consideration was given to whether we
should allocate the amount of scarce
material that we used in the a-bombs
over to an untried project whether we
would allocate the scientists who were
scarce in that top flight range over to
this new project and tried with maybe
the chance that all of that material and
all that time of the scientists would be
wasted and also the fact that we had to
appropriate about a billion dollars in
order to go into this project well dr.
Oppenheimer's reply to the Atomic Energy
Commission charges last week made it
clear that his general advisory
committee was against the hydrogen bomb
in the beginning now what I'd like to
ask you is do you think it was correct
for the Atomic Energy Commission to have
suspended dr. Oppenheimer under the new
security regulations
first I'd like to answer the first part
of it the general Advisory Committee of
scientists did not take action against
going ahead with the h-bomb they merely
took action against going ahead on a
crash basis they say that's the first
part of your question the second part of
your question I think it would be
improper for me to pass judgment on dr.
Oppenheimer because it is upon this
question that the this high top flight
review board is now having hearings with
dr. Oppenheimer and other witnesses and
they will be the ones that will pass
judgment on whether it was proper or not
I have confidence in this committee of
three and believe they'll do a good job
represent of olive oil you were talking
about the unearthly effects of the
hydrogen bomb in your opinion will the
hydrogen bomb and it's blast effects
have any possible use for peacetime use
of atomic energy well again we're going
into the unknown when we predict this on
this point i would say that most of the
scientists do not believe that we can
harness the hydrogen explosion as we are
about to harness the atomic explosion
but who knows what the future will bring
well you have often been quoted as
believing that the people should be
toward told more about hydrogen bomb
explosions could you tell us in what
general area you think that we should
know more than we've been told yes I
believe that the American people should
be told the truth about what these
weapon effects are not how to make the
bomb or how many we have or how to
deliver them or detonate them but they
should be told what the effects will be
both on our enemies and on ourselves if
they're used against us I think this is
basic knowledge that they must have to
intelligently divide the truth from
these terrible rumors that are going
around which saved this that that you
might set the atmosphere on fire or that
you might devastate a fifteen hundred
mile wide two thousand mile a long area
these are just in the field of fancy and
I think unless the people are told the
truth they can't tell between truth and
fancy you don't think that Admiral
straws is appearance that the
president's press conference recently
was a sufficient announcement on well I
was very much in favor of everything
that Admiral straw said that the
president's press conference I call
attention to the fact however that the
information he gave was on the bomb that
was exploded in November of 19 and 52 it
was not on the vomit was exploded on
March the first are the later bombs
didn't shared with the fishermen well he
talked about I'm talking about bombs now
you're talking about fishermen yes he
did talk about the fishermen who
accidentally got into the path of some
radioactivity but he didn't talk about
the size of the bomb and these films
that are going around are about the bomb
of 1952 not about the March first bomb
and I say that if the people were
entitled to the facts on the on the 1952
bomb they're also entitled to the facts
on the nineteen fifty four bombs so
representative Allah family ask you is
there any reason to believe that these
hydrogen bomb blast could be causing any
effect on the weather in the united
states around the world or disturbing
the cycles of nature as many people fear
i believe the best information we have
from weather scientists and other
scientists is that this is not true well
may i ask you sir do you think are a
civil defense if it were warned about
the effects of these bombs is capable of
handling a total war in which they were
used well i'd like to I'd like to say
this much that there is no complete
answer to hydrogen bomb attack we have
no complete defense against it and
there's no complete answer to it but
there are many answers to things which
can be done which would lessen the
effect of a hydrogen bomb attack and we
could put our country in order if we had
an effective type of civilian defense I
say that we do not at this time have an
effective civilian defense in the United
States and I say that it is necessary
because I believe that civilian defense
which includes the protection of the
people on the industrial line that are
making the products of war is just as
necessary as to have the jet planes and
the other implements of war you've got
to keep the pipeline field or these
things cannot be used in military action
and that's what I'm very much interested
in I'd like to see a very effective a
civilian defense
in other words you think that the
civilians would be on the front line of
any defense in this country in the event
of a third world war or a war that if it
didn't start with atoms and hydrogen
bombs what might end with him I'm sure
and there's no responsible military are
our civilian authority that will say
that the civilians will not be in the
front line I think they will be now I
think in order to have this effective
we've got to have presidential
leadership we've got to have recognition
of the fact that civilian defense is
just as important as military defense
and offense and we've got to have one
step to do that would be to put the
civilian defense agency on a cabinet
status level to give it the prestige
commensurate with the importance of the
job that is to be done another thing
that I think is absolutely imperative is
Federal Financing the people of the
different cities will not take the
complete job of Federal Financing for
the benefit of the nation and they
shouldn't have to another thing I think
you've got to consider target areas
rather than just target cities and
another thing you've got to have
compulsory participation you cannot
depend upon volunteer participation if
you have a real civilian defense well in
the lines of civilian defense
representative jalapeño would you advise
as well Peterson the Secretary has that
people get out of town and go to the
desert or go to the mountains or is
there some other kind of defense
possible well there's there's many
different kinds of Defense and and the
defense would have to be tailored to the
individual target area taking into
consideration roads of egress rivers and
water courses and many other factors
which have to do with either evacuation
our proper kind of hibernation let's
call it rosa de paula fielder may I ask
you is the final question you said
before that you thought we should go on
with these tests and we were learning a
great deal from them have we learned
anything really useful from these
hydrogen bomb tests in the Far Pacific
well one thing that we have learned we
have learned
that we can make a hydrogen bomb and we
know that Russia has made unexploded a
thermonuclear type of bomb now if we
were not in a position to know that we
can do this we would in my opinion be at
the mercy of a subversive full with
ideals different from ours and they
could more or less right to ticket for
world domination but now that we do know
that we can do it we are on a parody as
far as strength is concerned with them
and possibly ahead of them thank very
much for than Apollo feel it's been a
most interesting to have you here
tonight thank you the opinions expressed
on the lawn gene chrono scope were those
of the speakers the editorial board for
this edition of the lawn gene chrono
scope was there a lesser and Lewis banks
our distinguished guest was the
Honorable chat Hollifield representative
from California